looking for the first time since Wagner
group mercenaries staged a mutiny from
the country's South
Putin described evgeny pregosian's
troops as Patriots but declared any
attempts to organize internal unrest are
doomed to fail he also thanked the
Russian people for what he called Unity
following the brief Revolt from armed
mercenaries over the weekend
Daniel Hawkins is live for us in Moscow
so tell us about the significance of
Putin's statement and what he did and
didn't say
well this statement was previewed by
Dimitri peskov the Russian presidential
spokesman as Destiny defining for Russia
that really wasn't the case but it was
Destiny defining really for uh Evgeni
pregozian and for his Wagner military
group the president was careful to avoid
saying precautions name throughout his
speech like he avoided saying it over
his address to the nation on the weekend
as well and it's interesting to analyze
the wording of a speech as well because
he called those soldiers those pilots
who lost their lives in this clash as
Heroes and he referred to the Wagner
Fighters as Patriots avoiding carefully
to condemn them as traitors or mutineers
the language you picked was very careful
To Tread that fine line between stamping
his authority and saying look what
happened over the weekend
uh should not be repeated uh was a
threat to Russian statehood and security
and could have brought Russia to Civil
War at the same time trying really to
um I guess you could say bring the sides
uh bring the sides apart or bring the
sides together however you could look at
it and very much confirming uh those uh
the the news over the weekend that those
talks behind closed doors with president
lukashenko of Belarus confirmed that
President uh that time you've gaining
precaution would be allowed to go to
Belarus but also confirming and this was
news to many Russians that the Wagner
Fighters would also be allowed to go to
Belarus and allegedly uh that confirms
this chatter this telegram chatter
speculation while Russian war
correspondence that Wagner Fighters had
been seen Crossing into Belarus with
their equipment with their military
hardware so certainly a very interesting
development and we'll be waiting
for the the second part of that speech
potentially more announcements uh
following this very key meeting between
Vladimir Putin and the heads of the
Russian security forces and Armed Forces
uh Sergey Shogun Russia's defense
minister as well
indeed so talk us through who's at that
meeting and why they're so important I
mean presumably that they have questions
to answer about how Prego and his men
managed to get so close to Moscow
there certainly will be questions
throughout so I'm just keeping an eye on
the uh the Russian lines coming in we
are getting footage in of this meeting
excuse me between the Russian president
and the heads of the security services
and the real novelty the Russian State
mainly news agency is saying that Putin
at this meeting with the heads of
Security Services thank them for their
work for their service
and offered to analyze the situation
that developed over the weekend so
perhaps not quite what was predicted
quite not the uh the firings the um
moving around positions the uh the real
anger that could have been in that
meeting uh according to this uh this
footage that's being released publicly
at least part of the footage the
president is thanking them and saying
look let's get together and analyze what
happened and have a brainstorm
about what's going on so uh that's uh
the the first part what goes on behind
closed doors of course remains to be
seen but certainly the image coming up
publicly the image being projected by
the kremlin's uh uh while they're coming
in by Russian uh State media agencies is
uh one of Unity One of reflection and
one as I say of trading that fine line
trying not to offend either side and
saying look what happened perhaps was a
a tragic mistake as Vladimir Putin
called those actions by the Wagner
Fighters and uh really reflection on
thank goodness worse was awarded worse
Bloodshed worse Civil War so perhaps
more announcements coming out of out of
that meeting
um and the announcement from president
lukashenko of Belarus now confirmed not
for tonight but rather for tomorrow that
announcement was initially due to happen
in parallel between the president's uh
president lukashenko's announcement will
take place tomorrow at a meeting with
Belarusian press tell us a little bit
about the the position in Belarus though
I mean
how significant is it that Belarus has
got involved at this stage in trying to
essentially bail out the situation in
Russia
well Belarus is uh Russia's closest Ally
lukashenko is a one of Putin's closest
allies as well as as a state belonging
to the union state of Russia and Belarus
the country has special privileges and
of course in preceding weeks and months
Russia moved nuclear-capable weapons
into Belarus which certainly riled uh
Washington and uh Western leaders as
well that was done in retaliation of
course says the Kremlin for the actions
of the West and for NATO so clearly
Belarus is very much a key link if you
like in the chain of the kremlin's
security plans for Russia security
status for Russia quite where the
vlogmas presence on better Russian
territory fits in
is very hard to say I don't think
anybody could have predicted even
yesterday
um that the Wagner Fighters would have
been allowed to move to Belarus keeping
all their weapons given as uh some of
our guests have said the threat they
created for the Kremlin moving to within
Striking Distance of Moscow that's
certainly a very interesting development
but the Russian president of course had
to also strike a balance between
stamping Authority as I say and keeping
to his word and his word was when those
negotiations took place that precaution
would be allowed to go to Belarus and
the Wagner Fighters would not be
prosecuted and what will happen long
term again uh remains open-ended but
this speech seems to confirm that and
these images coming out of this meeting
right now as we speak with the heads of
the security service the chief of
defense the defense minister again a
message of uh Unity things are
proceeding as normal let's get together
and unite now now is not the time to uh
to play the blame game now is not the
time to as I say to to blame officials
but to get together and reflect on
what's going on Daniel Hawkins thank you
very much
the White House weighed in earlier with
National Security Council spokesman John
Kirby explaining that the U.S used
diplomatic channels to communicate with
Moscow during the Mutiny he also said
the US was not taking sides in what he
described as an internal matter
we also made clear to all our allies and
partners that the United States was not
involved and would not get involved in
these events and that we view them as
internal Russian matters
we delivered that same message to the
Russians themselves through appropriate
diplomatic channels I'll emphasize as
the president did just a little bit ago
that it's too early to speculate on the
impact these events might have or to
reach any definitive conclusions except
one of course and that is that no matter
what happens next we're going to stay
closely coordinated with those allies
and partners and we're going to continue
to stand with Ukraine
is live in Washington DC so there's not
been much reaction so far to the latest
from from Moscow
I think they're still trying to
understand what what happened this
really does seem to have been an organic
internal matter I think that's why the
White House and the state department
have been at such pains to say look this
time really it wasn't us because
obviously the US's history of regime
change in in countries around the world
so they were very quick to say no it
wasn't us and now we we heard from Kirby
there in the state department that
that's exactly what they were saying to
the Russians look I know we have some
you know Bad Blood to put it mildly but
this isn't this isn't us and I think
that that reflects that that reality
that despite a lot of the rhetoric we're
here in Washington from all the pundit
class and everyone else there is that
understanding that what Putin does so
successfully is manage all the different
factions in Russia very successfully and
it's not clear that anyone else could
take his place and if you look at the
the makeup of what may have been an
alleged coup may have been just a
mutineer on on military tactics if this
really was
backed my really important crime
officials trying to overthrow Putin that
would mean this is a coup from the
extreme right and from people who are
saying Putin has been too lenient on
Ukraine do you really want them to have
the the nuclear Arsenal it's true that
the US has been supporting the overthrow
of Putin for some time but that but they
weren't there guys people are going to
look kindly on the US and this this
wasn't that Bunch so we had all these
extraordinary statements the White House
is John Kirby saying regime change in
Russia is not U.S policy and this this
actually just I just saw this from the
state department spokesperson the U.S
doesn't take a position on the
leadership of Russia or its Ministry of
Defense I mean that's quite
extraordinary when you think about the
rhetoric that we hear from the US on a
daily basis I think there might be a
sense that
there's that sense perhaps then of
relief that Putin appears to have
studied things perhaps the sign that the
Wagner group is going to be allowed to
reform in some way under Russian
government which isn't is not a sign of
a of a of a president who is weak at the
moment but there's also clearly a
dilemma and we're hearing two attitudes
now coming out from the foreign policy
blob in Washington and we've heard that
for the last few days which is one
saying all right clearly Putin has
weakened despite what we've just heard
there
that we're going to help Ukraine now
give them even more weapons really now
you know Putin's on the back foot we've
got to go in but I think what this has
also shown though is if there is another
Ukrainian Battlefield upset there are
many forces in Russia who will use
whatever Lincoln said with those cracks
that they'd ever seen before to actually
say oh put it hasn't been strong enough
and they may see sees the the you know
some sort of Reigns one once again or
attempt to whatever this wasn't about
Putin about the war in Ukraine being
waged at all it was actually very much
about you know him Putin having having
not helped the the military on the
ground in Ukraine and then there's Rifts
that we just heard from from Moscow
about you know who should be in charge
who should probably be making money out
of illness and so on so it's that's lead
to that dilemma because it does suggest
them but you know more Battlefield
successes and Russia being pushed back
well as Lincoln said those are the
cracks we're looking at right now that
could rebel against Putin again and then
and then where does the nuclear Arsenal
go when then where does the Russia's
stability game interesting though that
as they mentioned that they'd use
diplomatic channels to communicate with
Moscow during the Mutiny itself and
there was some suggestion that
um U.S intelligence at least knew that
it was about to happen before it
happened but in on this instance didn't
actually publicize the fact that they
knew
but then we heard so we heard that
they'd been monitoring the movement of
Wagner troops
but you know even up until everything
kicked off
um the National Security uh advisor or
Jake um Jake sorry it's been such a big
day but look I mean but but the Joint
Chiefs of Staff and um and and Jake
Sullivan they both had international
travel plans this weekend and they were
still going ahead with that and then
suddenly they had to say oh actually you
know what we better watch what's
happening so that suggested that they
may have seen the troop Maneuvers but
they didn't know when when things would
actually happen
thank you very much indeed
let's take a listen back now to some of
what the Russian president said earlier
dear friends today I address once again
all Russian citizens I thank you for
your endurance solidarity and patriotism
civil solidarity showed that any Ransom
any attempts to organize internal unrest
are doomed to fail
s
from Moscow he's a defense and foreign
policy analyst thanks very much indeed
for being with us what do you make of
Putin's speech this evening
uh well this was a victory speech uh
obviously saying that the Russian public
to show the public that Putin's there
Putin's in control that everything's
fine there are some maybe problems yet
but we had uh whether that storm and
everything is going to be good well
that's what the reader show is kind of
projecting of course that doesn't really
mean that the problems have this this
dissipated and everything is fine it's
not fine actually because Putin has
called on the partner hikers to joined
the defense Ministry and they are not
doing it
they are still there with their weapons
they're well organized they're the best
fighting force apparently in the land
right now and what will be their next
move is not clear right now most likely
they feel threatened uh maybe if they'll
go to Belarus but how they go there it's
not clear well they go with side weapons
or all they go with their with more
heavy weapons and what that will mean
when they will be not far from small
ends uh on a queer straight line
a highway waiting to Moscow most much
closer than uh they are right now
because they moved on Moscow from the
south and came up to the Oka River
that's a very wide river and it goes
from east to uh from west to east and it
kind of it's a natural barrier from ma
to Moscow from the south and there's no
natural barriers from the West they're
being will be based in Belarus they
didn't disappear tell us about preggers
himself because he issued that defiant
statement today
um but we do we know where he is exactly
and what his plans are
well he's with his troops that gives him
security he's within with his troops but
I mean we should not just focus on Craig
ocean this is not just his personal
ambition the Wagner
mercenaries have their own agenda
and if precaution won't leave them aware
they want to go maybe they'll like other
videos
they are a force to be reckoned with
they cannot be just written off they
didn't lay down their arms they didn't
surrender and they have their own agenda
and they understand that if they
surrender that they'll be kind of picked
out one by one
so this crisis
despite what Putin projects as a kind of
thought of Victory is not yet a total
Victory because the main problem the
Wagner group
are Fighters is still there they're
still working there and they moved to
Moscow actually just small fraction of
what they had they can move again
so how they're going to deal with them I
mean Putin said they should join the
defense Ministry they're not joining the
defense Ministry they're in defiance and
will they have their own even social and
most likely political agenda so what and
what about this meeting with the head of
the intelligence and also the kind of
military military top brass can you tell
us about what you expect will come out
of that I mean do you see any heads
rolling or anything
I believe that they're right now
thinking how to deal with the popular
group because they are there they're a
problem
they didn't disappear okay if he can
deal with precaution maybe just one man
so I mean right now anyway he's also
apparently the Russian services that
were always good and eliminating Putin's
enemies have not been able to do that
but uh so we're talking about maybe over
10 000 uh pardoned battle veterans and
this is a force to be reckoned with so
they'll have to find some kind of policy
to make that problem disappear so that
the Wagner groups doesn't become become
again a political challenge to the
entire regime and that's not really yet
victory victory will come if to Putin if
he manages to make the brachner group
some kind of disappear in some kind of
Fair Way
thank you very much indeed for your
thoughts on the subject thank you
thank you
European leaders are distancing
themselves from the events in Russia
describing them as an internal matter EU
foreign ministers have been meeting in
Luxembourg while the head of NATO is
visiting troops in Lithuania Dominic
Kane reports from Berlin
unanimity of purpose was very clear to
be seen at Luxembourg as ministers
convened EU foreign ministers convened
to discuss the most important issues
with the situation in Ukraine and indeed
Russia high on the agenda and the German
foreign minister Angelina belbach spoke
for many of her colleagues insofar as
their view of what has been happening is
concerned this is what she had to say
what is clear is this is a domestic
power struggle in Russia and we're not
getting involved Putin is destroying his
own country we see the devastating
consequences of the Russian war of
aggression also on Putin's system of
power we see that Russia's leadership is
increasingly striking back at itself and
we see massive cracks in Russian
propaganda
at the same time as the meeting in
Luxembourg there was also a meeting
taking place in Vilnius the Lithuanian
Capital where the Secretary General of
NATO Yen stradenberg was meeting the
Lithuanian defense minister but also the
German defense minister talking about
the need for people to treat the
situation in Ukraine and Russia as
particularly important and stressing his
view of what has been taking place
also demonstrates how how difficult and
dangerous it is for President Putin to
be reliant on Mercenaries that has
actually turned against him and it also
demonstrates that
it is hard to predict exactly what will
now happen in the next days and weeks
but we should not make the mistakes that
we are underestimating the Russians so
we need to continue to provide support
to Ukraine the German government has
made clear that it is prepared to
sanction the deployment permanently of
four thousand of its soldiers to
Lithuania it already has a presence in
Lithuania and has done so for some
considerable time and it is at the
request of the Lithuanian government but
it's also a clear statement by Germany
that it wants to bolster the Baltic
states that are a buffer as it were
between Belarus and Russia on the
one-handed EU and NATO on the other
certainly that's the view coming from
the government here in Berlin